Speaker 1: Let's go next to a treatise
from Boston. A treatise from Boston. Uh,
what are you, like, a Dune fan?
Speaker 3: Yes, I am very much. I say this as I'm
sitting right next to my doing poster. All right.
Speaker 1: Well, don't sit too close.
Speaker 3: In, hear me?
Speaker 1: All right. I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Excellent. Okay, so I have a couple of
questions. So a barney in 2016 and 2020 ran and,
you know, almost got the nomination but wasn't
able to hear it. But in doing that, he was able
to sort of renew a progressive movement within
the country and within the Democratic Party.
And somewhat similar in my home state of
Massachusetts, ranked choice. Voting was
on the ballot back in 2020 and wasn't able to
get passed. But now countless more people that
I talked to and that I've interacted with and
that I see now know about RCP and support it.
I maybe well might seem a bit of an optimist, but
do you think that there is merit in the byproduct
of a loss that eventually leads to some sort
of victory? Or do you think those are more just
self-contained victories with limited success?
Speaker 1: No, sometimes that is the case. I mean,
it's very hard in any particular situation to
say, could this defeat actually be what eventually
rockets us to a victory? But in business, that's
extraordinarily common, where a business will have
an initial product or service which fails and that
allows them to realize, Oh, there's actually this
completely different way to do it. There's this
better idea. And were it not for the failure,
if the initial failure had instead been a modest
success, they would have never come across the
major success. And the same thing can happen.
It's just hard in any particular case to say,
okay, does the failure of ranked choice mean that
eventually it will be an even bigger success? It's
so hard to say, but conceptually that's not an
infrequent occurrence. Something fails. It lets
you reset and figure out the best way or the right
way or whatever. And then you have an even bigger
success than you otherwise would have had.
Speaker 3: Great. Yeah, no, I definitely,
definitely agree with, you
know, Coke, for example.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So what I have actually read
about that. So. Coke introduced was New Coke the
one that was clear or it was just the new flavor?
Speaker 3: No, that's Crystal Pepsi. New Coke was
like they sort of changed. I might be getting
this a little wrong, but new Coke, they, like,
changed the recipe and tried to, like, rebrand
Coke. This was during the culture wars in the
eighties and it backfired badly. So they brought
back Coke Classic and go classic did much,
much better than the new Coke, right?
Speaker 1: Yep. I've read extensively,
although it was years ago about that that era.
It's actually fascinating even as a non soda
drinker, generally speaking, like myself.
Speaker 3: All right. I did have a follow
up question. Sure. So as we know, Biden is
he's not very popular right now. I believe
that recent poll said that 71% of Americans don't
want him to seek reelection, which isn't doesn't
spell great for the Democrats in 2024. And I've
heard whispers and murmurs that Gavin Newsom
would be in his in his absence if he doesn't seek
reelection. Something that I've I'm not I don't
really have much to back this up. It's more just a
hypothesis. But I'm worried that the DNC was sort
of panic and they'd find a moderate Democrat
or somebody who was maybe not so moderate,
like Tulsi Gabbard, for example, who know if
you see she has. No I was worried they were
just going to just throw her to the front. No.
Speaker 1: Tulsi is not even a Democrat at this
point. If the DNC certainly might anoint
someone, they might say we're anointing
Kamala in Joe Biden's absence on the
ticket or whoever, but they're not
going to go to Tulsi. Tulsi is essentially
a Republican. She spoke at CPAC, you know.
Speaker 3: Yes, she spoke at CPAC.
Speaker 1: It's crazy. Now that the don't
worry about that. That's not going to happen.
Speaker 3: Okay? Yeah. Just like a
just a general hypothesis. Yeah, but.
Yeah. Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great to hear
from you. There goes a treatise from
Boston. Great to speak to people. That does
it for today. But we will take calls again.